[Music]
the Republican nominee in Georgia's
super close race for governor wants the
FBI to investigate alleged hacking by
Democrats Brian Kemp is also Georgia's
Secretary of State his office says in a
statement we open an investigation into
the Democratic Party of Georgia after
receiving information from our legal
team about failed efforts to breach the
online voter registration system Georgia
Democrats say the allegations are false
Kemp didn't mention the issue during
President Trump's political rally in
Macon Georgia yesterday but made a
last-minute plea to voters I cannot do
this without you the radical left is
pouring millions into Georgia they're
energized they're energized they're
mobilized their itching
they are itching you all the turn
Georgia into California Stacey Abrams is
the Democratic candidate for governor
and former House Minority Leader for the
state assembly she's with us from
Savannah we invited Secretary of State
kam to appear and he declined
good morning Stacey Abrams I want to
start with these allegations which
revolve around an email exchange has the
FBI or Homeland Security contacted your
campaign or the Democratic Party as far
as you know they have not and let's be
clear Brian Kemp was informed of this
flaw in his security system on Friday he
failed to act and instead on Sunday
without any evidence decided to try to
cast aspersions on Democrats we have
nothing to do with this this is yet
another example of his failure to secure
the information of more than 6 million
voters he has failed at this twice
already and we know that when he gets
caught he blames everyone else this lack
of accountability is not infinite of
anything other than his failure to do
his job there is no evidence there is
there's no there's not even a
conversation about Democrats having
anything to do with this other than
learning along with everyone else that
Brian Kemp had failed once again to be
the effective secretary do you think
it's gonna affect the vote come Tuesday
what I think will happen is that once
again this shows a pattern of voter
suppression on the part of Brian Kemp
trying to scare people out of casting
their votes but we've been working hard
for 18 months to increase the sense of
security that people should have about
our democracy writ large and we know the
best antidote
- voter suppression is voter engagement
and that's why we're excited about the
overwhelming number of people who turned
out an early voting already in Georgia
and we intend to see them there on
Election Day are you concerned about the
fairness of this election I'm concerned
that there is someone seeking
advancement to higher office having
failed to do this fundamental job as the
guardian of the public trust of our
democracy Brian Kemp does not deserve a
promotion however I'm not gonna focus on
him alone I'm focusing on the voters of
Georgia talking about education about
jobs about expanding Medicaid because if
they will cast their ballots and voice
their concerns about these issues we
will have a fair election because so
many of us will vote there will be no
question about the outcome you know
president Trump is you know Stacey
Abrams campaigned in Macon Georgia
yesterday he said this about you
described you as one of the most extreme
left-wing opponents saying that if you
put Stacey in there you'll have Georgia
turn into Venezuela so how are you
dealing with comments like that about
you and your campaign
I told tell people to look at my record
I'm the only candidate in this race
who's worked across the aisle who's
gotten a ratings from the Georgia
Chamber of Commerce and the friend of
labor award I'm the only one with
detailed plans on how we improve access
to education in the state of Georgia how
we cover half a million people with
access to affordable health care and how
we create good-paying jobs across the
state of Georgia my opponent doesn't
have a record what he has is rhetoric
and failed policies and failed behavior
and so I think when people look at my
record and they look at my plans they
will know that I'm the only candidate
who has their best interest at heart but
did you know voters don't often do a
deep deep dive they look at the
headlines and Brian camp is saying about
you that this is a forest this this is a
distraction there are counter charges
back and forth what do you do to keep
people focused who are just sort of sick
of both sides now at this point well I
would say this I think that what's
happened over the last few months is
that Brian camp has consistently behaved
in a way that is not worthy of this
office and what voters have seen is not
a back-and-forth they've seen one person
who throws out desperate attacks who has
to basically blame everyone else for his
failures and I've run a consistent
campaign and I've never pointed a
shotgun at anyone I've never blown
anything up I've been talking about the
same three issues since the day I
launched his campaign good jobs good
healthcare and good education for our
kids referring there to images that
Brian Kemp had in his campaign but
statement you said there's no evidence
but isn't the Kemp campaign pointing to
an email exchange in which there was
discussion of vulnerabilities in the
state's system isn't that what they're
saying is the evidence so let's be clear
there was an email sent by our voter
Protection Division to cyber security
folks because they'd receive this
information and we did the right thing
which is we got information that there
was a vulnerability we sent it to
cybersecurity folks because it's the
voter Protection Division of our
campaign but the issue was that Brian
Kemp was told about this days before and
did nothing to alert the public to the
fact that there was another flaw and hit
the system he's responsible for
overseeing and instead of addressing the
flaw and taking responsibility he
decided to go to a desperate place and
blame Democrats for simply alerting
cybersecurity experts
to his failure okay Stacey Abrams we're
gonna have to leave it there thank you
again we invited Secretary of State
Brian Kem to appear and he declined our
invitation